Well, we know that if we only look at x as less than 3, this would be the
interval we would have. And, if we were only to look at x as greater than 7, we
would have this. Remember that interval notation shows us what the minimum and
maximum values that x is limited to are. And, of course, whether or not those
are included are shown by the brackets. But, in this case, we need to include
both of these regions. We do this by showing a u between the two of them. This u
here, stands for union. All the values that it can take on are shown by having a
union of this region with this region. We're taking all these numbers from both
areas and putting them together in one big heap. X will be somewhere in that one
big group of numbers.